if you're gonna Sue wait to after the
fight whoop his ass and then do that I
don't like Jake and him going we're to
Garner his wages and he only make $6,000
like okay so we what's the agenda here
to ruin his life like that's that's not
cool we we were talking earlier about
just how complex this this scenario is
I'm not saying this is right maybe how
could I level the playing field a little
bit right not only that but I think
maybe in Nina's mind she's saying to
herself like yo if I the faster I get
this lawsuit out the faster he's going
to stop the scenario is just so complex
and we've been talking about it for the
past like 20 minutes now that it's just
really hard to put a one sentence answer
on it if that Mak sense I don't I don't
like any of it I don't like any of it
from either side I think Logan should
say hey we'll drop the lawsuit if you
beat me put the stakes into the fight
get us interested in the fight because
when they both sign up for this fight
the goal is to get as many eyeballs make
as much money as possible to fight each
other cool add add more Stak to the
fight